BUT, LOOK, SHOULD WE REALLY
BE SURPRISED BY ANY OF THIS?
THE WAGE AND THE FURY ON THE
LEFT OVER TRUMP'S ELECTION,
AND THEIR FRANTIC SEARCH FOR
SOMETHING, ANYTHING TO
EXPLAIN WHY HILLARY CLINTON
LOST HAS BECOME A TOTAL
OBSESSION.
THEY THOUGHT COAT LUCIEN
WOULD INVALIDATE THE
ELECTION.
>> THERE IS, HOWEVER,
EXTENSIVE PRESS REPORTING ON
THE RELATIONSHIPS BETWEEN
THE RUSSIANS AND THE
INDIVIDUALS ASSOCIATED WITH
BOTH THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN AND
THE INCOMING ADMINISTRATION.
>> WE NOTE RUSSIANS PLAYED A
VERY SIGNIFICANT ROLE IN THE
CAMPAIGN.
>> SO YOU HAVE SEEN DIRECT
EVIDENCE OF COLLUSION?
>> I DON'T WANT TO GO INTO
SPECIFICS, BUT I WILL SAY
THAT THERE IS EVIDENCE THAT
IS NOT CIRCUMSTANTIAL.
>> I'VE ALWAYS SAID THAT I
BELIEVE THERE WAS COLLUSION.
>> Laura: POOR AUNTE MAXINE
AFTER ALL THESE MONTHS AND
SPECIAL COUNSEL AND
CONGRESSIONAL INVESTIGATION
TOO NUMEROUS TO COUNT, WHAT
HAVE THEY ACTUALLY FOUND?
A MULTI-MILLION-DOLLAR PILE
OF NOTHING.
WELL, GOOD LUCK TO THE DNC
IN TRYING TO MAKE A CASE IN
COURT WITH THESE STAR
WITNESSES.
>> HAVE YOU SEEN ANY
EVIDENCE THAT THIS DIRT,
THESE EMAILS WERE EVER GIVEN
TO THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN?
>> NOT SO FAR.
>> ANY REFLECTION OF
COLLUSION BETWEEN MEMBERS OF
THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN AND THE
RUSSIANS, THERE WAS NO
EVIDENCE OF THAT, INCLUDED
IN OUR REPORT.
>> I UNDERSTAND THAT.
BUT DOES IT EXIST?
>> NOT TIME.
>> WHEN YOU
NO WHEN YOU
NOTWHEN YOU
NOT TEN YOU
NOT TO  YOU
NOT TO MYOU
NOT TO MY KNOWLEDGE.>> WHEN YOUL
NOT TO MY KNOWLEDGE.>> WHEN YOUA
NOT TO MY KNOWLEDGE.>> WHEN YOUN
NOT TO MY KNOWLEDGE.>> WHEN YOUD
NOT TO MY KNOWLEDGE.>> WHEN YOUY
NOT TO MY KNOWLEDGE.>> WHEN YOUU
TRUMP CAMPAIGN AND RUSSIAN
STATE ACTORS?
>> AS I SAID, GOWDY, I DON'T
DO EVIDENCE.
>> Laura: THERE IS A LOT
APPARENTLY THAT JOHN BRENNAN
DOESN'T DO.
THAT IS JUST A JOKE.
NOW, JUST IMAGINE THE
DISCOVERY PROCESS, THAT THIS
FOOLISHNESS EVER MADE IT TO
TRIAL?
LIKE WHAT IF THE DEFENSE
DEMANDS TO SEE THE DNC
SERVERS THAT THEY CLAIM
WIKILEAKS HACKED?
YOU KNOW, THE SERVERS, THE
DEMOCRATS REFUSED TO LET THE
FBI EXAMINE?
AND THAT THE FBI FOR SOME
STRANGE REASON NEGLECTED TO
SUBPOENA.